in the last few videos we've been slowly
building up our aggregate demand
aggregate supply model and the whole
point of us doing this is so that we can
give an explanation of why we have these
short-run economic cycles and we don't
just have this nice steady march of
economic growth due to population
increases and productivity improvements
but it's important to realize and it's
probably important to realize this for
all of what we study in micro and
macroeconomics that this is really this
is really just a model and in order to
do to use these models we had to make
suit huge huge simplifications and you
really should always view these models
with a critical eye that this is just
one way to view it you might not agree
with it you might think it's an
oversimplification you might want to
modify it in some place so it's very
important that you just view it only as
a model and the reason why we do that is
so that we can start to describe very
very very complicated things with fairly
simple graphs and mathematics so that we
can get our brain around something as
complicated as the economy something
that has hundreds of millions of actors
each of them with tens of billions of
neurons in their brain and doing all
sorts of crazy things we're able to
distill it down to simple lines and
curves and equations now in the last
video we studied we looked a little bit
at the long-run aggregate supply
aggregate supply in the long run and in
the a das model we assume that in the
long run the real productivity of
economy really doesn't depend on price
that price is really just a numeric
thing and in the long run people will
just adjust to producing or the economy
will just adjust to producing what is
capable of comfortably producing now
there's one thing that I want to stress
here this is not the maximum
productivity of the economy this is you
could view this as the natural let me
put it this way you could view this as
the so this right over here you could
view it as the natural output natural
the natural real output of the economy
and when I say natural it means that
there's always going to be some
inefficiencies in the economy people are
going to be switching jobs they might
have to retrain there's always going to
be turnover in things people are
obviously some people pass
in a job and then they have to hire
other people there's some normal or
natural rate of unemployment most in
most economies people aren't working
night and day they want to take some
time off they want to be able to rest
that there's because of other
interventions there aren't perfect
efficiencies and the economy as a whole
so this is kind of just a natural
healthy level of output there is some
theoretical level of output maybe we
could I'll draw it out here so this is
maybe some theoretical level of output
that you could view as maximum output
and maybe I'll draw it right over here
so this right over here might be maximum
output maximum given the population and
the technology that the population has
this is some type of theoretical thing
and it would be very hard to actually
quantify this is if people were just
working all out they weren't taking
vacations they weren't sleeping properly
they weren't you know every every person
was working in the put in the place that
they could be the most productive then
maybe you you would have some output
over here which is kind of impossible to
achieve so this is something below that
kind of a nice healthy level of output
for the economy now what we're going to
talk about in this video is aggregate
supply in the short run and what we're
going to see is is for this model to
work for the aggregate demand aggregate
supply model to work we have to assume
an upward sloping aggregate supply curve
in the short-run so it might look
something like this
might look something like this and
obviously obviously it would and
actually let me do it this way let's
assume let's assume that this is our
current level of prices are sitting
right over here this is our long-run
aggregate supply it's not depending on
prices just kind of a natural level of
output but in the short-run it might
look something like this
I'll do it in pink in the short-run it
might look something like this and I'm
asymptoting it up because obviously
obviously we can never get past that
optimal so what's going on here
what's going on in this curve so let me
I drew it a dotted line because easier
for me to draw something as a dotted
line that when I draw it as a straight
curve I my hand always shakes too much
this is the aggregate supply in the
short run and we'll see we need it to be
upward sloping for this model to to to
to provide a basis of explanation for
economic cycles and there's a couple of
explanations or a couple of you could
really view them as theories for why we
can justify an upward sloping aggregate
supply curve and the one way to think
about it and before I even justify why
it could be upward sloping when an
upward sloping curve is saying it's like
look this is just when people are you
know nicely you know they're they're
producing at their natural rate there's
going to be some unemployment in the
economy at this level right over here
but for whatever reason this upward
curve is saying that if prices go up if
prices go up then then the economy as a
whole is going to produce beyond that
natural rate so maybe they're going it's
going to bring in people from the from
from other parts or I guess you could
say it's going to suck people into the
labor pool who might have not been in
the labor pool to work a little bit
harder maybe they feel they can do a
little bit better now it might convince
factories to to run a little bit longer
it might convince people to take a few
of fewer vacations then the opposite
might be true if prices go down upward
sloping curve is saying that if prices
aggregate prices now this isn't just
pricing in one good or service if
aggregate prices going down it's saying
in the economy as a whole people might
be incentive to work a little bit less
people might drop out of the labor pool
in the short run remember this is all in
the short-run they might drop out of the
labor pool they might not run their
factories all out they might take more
vacations whatever else now let's think
about what are plausible justifications
for an upward sloping aggregate supply
curve so the first one is often called
the misperception theory let me write it
in white so it's the Mis misperception
theory and this is and it kind of makes
sense to me that if the aggregate let's
think about the situation where
aggregate prices are going up aggregate
prices are going up if I'm an individual
actor there may be I run a firm of some
kind
I might not notice immediately that it's
aggregate prices that are going up I
might just think that prices for my
goods or services are going up so I
might think that is actually a
micro economic phenomenon going on so I
miss perceiving it as a micro phenomenon
as something that's going on in my in my
market so if I think and this goes back
to the microeconomics if I think that
prices for my goods and services are
going up relative to others and remember
this is a misperception all prices are
going up but if I think this is
happening in the short run then the law
of supply kicks in then the law of
supply kicks in which is a micro
economic concept that if I feel that
real prices and it's not real prices
actually nominal prices but if I think
my relative prices are increasing I have
I have I'm motivated to produce more I
think I'm going to be more profitable it
only takes a little bit time for them
you realize that all my costs are going
up what I can purchase with my profits
are all going up so in real terms I'm
actually not getting any better and then
I'll probably settle in I'll settle back
to my level regular level of
productivity so while I think people are
demanding more of Sal's sprockets or
whatever I'm saying else I'll start
working overtime I might want to suck I
might want to hire more people run the
factories beyond kind of a you know even
a level I might I might defer
maintenance so that I can run the
factories longer and all the rest but
then over time I'm going to realize that
it was all I was just miss perceiving
things everything has gotten more
expensive I'm not making in real terms
an outsized profit right now and then my
and then so my level of productivity
might actually go back and when I talk
about me it's not me by myself that's
moving this whole economy remember I'm
just talking about one actor but this
this might be true of many many many
actors and acting in aggregate so as a
whole they might want to increase
productivity and then when they realize
that in real terms are actually not
making any more money and and that this
isn't sustainable they'll go back to
their natural level of output the other
theory that you will read about in
economic textbooks another theory or
explanation or justification why we
would have an upward sloping aggregate
supply curve in the short-run is
sometimes it's called the sticky wages
Theory sticky wages I like to extend it
to sticky sticky cost theory and
sometimes they'll articulate a separate
one called sticky prices but in my mind
these are all very similar so stick
wages to key cost and sticky prices
sticky sticky prices and it's the
general idea and that even if in
aggregate prices are increasing so the
whole economy prices are increasing in
all parts of the economy they all won't
increase at the same rate there are
parts of the economy where the prices
might be stickier than other places and
there's multiple reasons why prices
could be sticky
you could have wage contracts or people
might just be slow to realize prices are
going up and then renegotiating their
contracts you might have long term
agreements with suppliers - that you're
going to pay a fixed price over some
period of time you've already agreed for
the next year to pay it so even if
aggregate prices are going up it's going
to take a while in different parts of
the economy for contracts or for
transactions in those parts of the
economy to actually reflect those things
and then another reason why in parts of
the economy you might not have
everything move kind of in tandem or
everything move as quickly as you would
expect is because of something called
menu costs menu cost and menu costs are
just the idea that if prices are
changing if prices chain move up in the
next hour five percent it's not actually
trivial to increase your prices by five
percent for example if you're running a
restaurant you would have to reprint new
menus so that's where the name comes
from but it's not just true of a
restaurant it's true of anything it
would be true if you're any type of
supplier you would have to you'd have to
change your brochures you might have to
change your computer systems you have to
do a ton of things to actually make
things you have to tell tell your sales
force how the new pricing might be
different so there's a ton of things
that you have to do to actually change
costs so these menu costs actually might
slow down the ability for all prices to
move in tandem so some of them will be
stickier than others and the reason why
this can be a rationale for an upward
sloping aggregate supply curve in the
short run is if I'm in one of these
industries let's say that let's say my
my sales I am able to raise the prices
but let's say that the wages and my
costs are sticky I've already I've
already got into a long term wage
contract and the I've already on my
suppliers or can't raise their prices as
fast so in the short run
I'm going to say gee I'm making a lot of
profit now even in real terms because
these are my costs are being relatively
sticky while the money that's coming in
the door I'm able to raise the prices so
I'm going to try to produce more I'm
going to try to run the factories longer
maybe I'll defer maintenance so that I
can produce more maybe I'll try to hire
more people under these agreements maybe
I'll try to buy more goods and services
under these long-term costs and the
reason why I say that these are really
the same side of the same coin
is you can imagine here you have here
you have company company a that is able
to that is able to increase its prices
so its revenue starts going up and let's
say its supplier is company B it's
company B and this right over here is
sticky this is sticky so a buys maybe a
buys lemons from B and then sells
lemonade it's able to raise the price of
lemonade but it has a fixed price
contract on the lemons in the short run
eventually that will expire in the long
run can be B will be able to renegotiate
it upwards but A's costs are sticky but
this is B's prices are sticky so these
are really the same thing
that one's costs are really the others
prices